the moment of truth has arrived we
welcome you from petco park in downtown
san diego california
it is a peaceful setting but it is
anything but peaceful here as we get
ready for the 2020 american league
division series a six foot eight inch
tyler glass now for the tampa bay rays
when tyler glass now is on the hill it's
windy his last 10 starts the tampa bay
rays are 10-0 the scenario for glasnow
will be this he will be out there and
throwing as hard as he can for as long
as he can two men are out here is aaron
hicks
and on the first pitch into center field
kier meyer goes back and he's there and
that's a good start for tyler glass now
eight pitches a one two three inning
now the raise coming to bad we're off
and running in game five garrett cole
signed an historic contract this off
season the yankees signed him paid him
for moments like this meadows down 0-2
you got tomorrow i said i got tomorrow
and a 98-mile an hour wipeout fastball
and meadows is gone on three pitches and
now facing yandi diaz got an era in the
low ones during that time and cole
lets diaz get away that's a walk bases
are loaded now in this first inning and
cole ready for a 3-2 pitch
and it is a gold strike three that is a
big pitch early
garrett cole
gets the strikeout and the raised strand
the base is loaded
here's georgella so they're comfortable
with him as well coming in in any
situation there's a 99 mile an hour
fastball glass now strikes out or shella
there is out number two in that
strikeout number one for glasnow ray's
had the bases loaded last inning cole
able to get through it and a swing at a
miss he struck him out
on three pitches
three strikeouts now for cole he's been
a big game pitcher for sure and the 2-2
and a fastball at 99.
boy garrett cole
whatever he was trying to wrestle loose
in the first inning he has found it now
two up two down two k's
one two pitch and a wave that'll miss
garrett cole
comes back with three consecutive k's in
the second inning ray's had him on the
ropes ray's had the shift on could make
for an awkward double play opportunity
there's the big curve and
he goes at the top of the zone that time
got a generous call
and higashiyoka is out and glass now
picks up his second k according to plan
one time through the batting order
glass now is out
with dj lemay hugh coming up that is
their hallmark that's what it has
brought up here that's a chance for a
double play backhanded lau steps on the
back throw to first in time
a double play to end the inning
got himself in another full count he's
seen a lot of pitches last three times
up and he chased one that time at 100
low a little over aggressive
chased one out of the strike zone it's a
strikeout for garrett cole that's number
six already he's been a breakout star
this postseason not this time though
cole strikes him out another punch out
for garrett cole he's got seven now
rays go with four outfielders to
start this fourth inning with aaron
judge coming to the plate just two
pitches last hitting now judge in the
air to right field that ball is well hit
back at the wall meadows looks up and
it's gone
aaron judge gives the yankees the lead
first run of the ball game on a judge
opposite field home run so the yankees
strike first
three two two outs there he goes santa
dallas swings and misses coal with
another fist pump to mike zanino
and down goes
garrett cole
burns one off and that is another
strikeout number nine
cole's got two out to the fifth and in
the air right field judge going back
he's at the wall he leaps it's gone
judge could not get off a jump at that
ball he hit the wall
austin meadows has tied this game at
what a piece
a big moment in the game
as meadows delivers the long ball
and then fox will handle the national
league randy rosarino on the first pitch
sends it deep into left field gardner at
the wall and he's got it
oh rosarina
sends one deep but
gardner is there to make the play
chapman threw over the head of mike
brasso september 1st
3-2
sends one into left field gardner going
back and it is up and gone
mike rosso has homered
and the rays have a two to one lead
what a moment for brasso
tampa bay on top on the tenth pitch of
the at-bat
georgella
last hope for the yankees to try to
extend it
in this ninth inning and he hits a
bullet oh and it's caught at third by
wendell and that's it it is over the
tampa bay rays
in five games take down the yankees